electricity isn't the only alternative
to gasoline natural gas is another
option
skoda's g-tec system is the latest
attempt to construct a natural gas
hybrid capable of moving the masses
after the citigo gtech the czech
automaker now has two other
family-friendly models a sedan and a
station wagon
the 1.4 liter tsi hybrid motor is most
energy efficient when it's running on
natural gas when it burns gasoline it
has a capacity of 81 kilowatts
of frog mountains tells us that the car
has a radius of 1330 kilometers 410 of
them while running on natural gas
compared with a conventional 1.4 liter
gasoline engine the gtec has 22
kilowatts less capacity which of course
decreases performance when running on
natural gas the gtech station wagon has
a top speed of 193 kilometers an hour
and goes from zero to 100 in 11 seconds
but it emits only 97 grams of carbon
dioxide per kilometer that's 24 grams
less than a conventional gasoline engine
and benefits the environment
martin says the handling and chassis is
what one expects from a skoda octavia
the gtec makes no difference here in
fact it may be even more fun because
drivers can see from the fuel
consumption gauge how cheaply and
efficiently they're driving
now and again of course the gtech has to
stop for refueling preferably with
natural gas there are currently around
900 facilities for this in germany
two filler pipes are behind the fuel
flap
filling the car up with natural gas has
many drivers rubbing their eyes natural
gas is almost unbelievably cheap
says you need three kilograms of natural
gas to go 100 kilometers that's
fantastically efficient and drivers
don't have to sacrifice driving dynamics
scuda has put an impressive vehicle on
the
road the basic gtech station wagon costs
around 22
500 euros in germany some 2 000 euros
more than the conventional 1.4 liter
gasoline model
says sustainability begins with the cars
themselves and continues with the
production he says that skoda tries to
offer affordable and effective options
for customers on a budget
the interior of the car we tested is
pleasant bright and despite the hybrid
drive just as roomy as a standard
octavia the natural gas tank is located
under the floor of the trunk
the tank does reduce trunk space to 460
liters though
that's 25 percent smaller than in the
conventional gasoline model
the start stop system and brake energy
regeneration also help save fuel this
year readers of a german automotive
magazine chose the conventional octavia
as the most sensible car around and the
czech car maker has upped the stakes
with the natural gas model alternative
fuels are good for the environment and
the pocketbook
mountain says the gtech is worth the
asking price even if the hybrid model is
a bit pricier it pays for itself in the
long run at the moment natural gas only
costs around 1 euro and 10 cents since
the car uses only 3 kilograms per 100
kilometers you can drive that distance
for only 3 euros and 30 cents
conventional gasoline driven cars can't
compete
skoda is already producing the octavia
gtech in its main plant in the czech
republic
and the car will hit the showrooms this
month
for the first kashkai in 2007 nissan
essentially created the crossover
segment the aim was clear to develop an
suv that had all the advantages of a
normal passenger car
the qashqai's natural environment was
curvy country lanes not off-road terrain
and that was reflected in the way it
drove
current sasha cannot says that you only
need to drive a few meters to realize
that this is a car with a good chassis
the bumps in this road are smoothed out
and the steering is good
the design of the next generation of
qashqai's has been made sharper the
front end is dominated by the
arrow-shaped headlights with daytime
running lights the unpainted under-ride
protection and over-arches reveal the
vehicle's off-road pedigree
the sloping lines of the roof however
say passenger car the rear end with the
spoilers is also more sporty than robust
is there enough room for passengers in
the back
sasha says yes he has room for his knees
and his head although his hair does
brush the roof but that doesn't bother
him sasha also likes the view through
the sunroof the back seat is the best
place to enjoy that
the view to the rear is restricted by
the car's design
on the other hand nissan offers the
surround view system which gives you a
bird's eye view of the vehicle that's
particularly helpful for parking
perspectives
the system is a standard feature of the
deluxe version
unfortunately the interior looks cheaper
than it actually is
still this model does have partial
leather seats and a leather covered gear
stick
says that if you've got your key in your
pocket you can unlock the trunk like
this the trunk has a volume of 430
liters which can be expanded to
1585 leaders by putting the seats down
the rear seating is divided in two
whereas a triple division would have
been better that makes the car less
versatile than it could be
the car we tested is equipped with a 1.6
liter diesel engine
all-wheel drive and an automatic
transmission or options
we're happy with the front wheel drive
the car has a capacity of 96 kilowatts
and a top speed of 183 kilometers an
hour
the automatic transmission makes the
motor a bit sluggish it takes 11.1
seconds to go from zero to a hundred
nissan developed the technology in
conjunction with renault
sasha says with the new cash qashqai
nissan has improved on something that
was already good with its fuel
efficiency and good basic features it's
a serious alternative for small families
the standard version of the car costs
just under 20 000 euros in germany
meaning it's an affordable vehicle that
combines safety with drivability like
earlier models the nissan qashqai has
the potential to be a real hit
the hybrid hyundai i-10 runs on liquid
petroleum gas and uses 6.5 liters per
100 kilometers and is rated to travel
450 kilometers before switching to the
conventional gasoline engine in germany
the hyundai i-10 with its
environmentally friendly 1.0 lpg engine
and the trend features will set you back
around 13 000 euros
the bmw concept roadster provides a
first look at what could be the new
motorcycle roadster generation with a
water-cooled 2-cylinder boxer engine the
1170 cubic meter engine has a capacity
of 92 kilowatts with 7 750 rpm and a
maximum torque of 125 newton meters
explains that the association of
international motor vehicle
manufacturers originally started the
automobile international in leipzig to
give imported makes a larger showcase
now germany's second biggest automotive
trade fair also features many german car
makers
bmw has a production facility in leipzig
so it has nothing less than its entire
range at the ami joining the products
already out there are some new releases
bmw's roland krueger explains that this
year the carmaker is presenting two
european premiers and one german premier
the active tour and premiering for
europe the new x4 and the convertible m4
porsche also has a plant near the trade
fair grounds and will not let bmw leave
it in the dust even if it has no
premiers of its own but many of the
luxury models are seldom seen on the
streets so they're just as much a treat
for the ami visitors
audi is celebrating the world premiere
of its s7 sports car the 4-liter v8
engine puts out a killer 331 kilowatts
of power
what's thoroughly new about this one is
the design starting with a single frame
grille in front and many other
highlights the s7 v8 twin turbocharged
engine features cylinder on demand so it
can be driven as a v8 or a v4 cylinder
on demand
vw is celebrating the 40th anniversary
of its golf with a special model the
golf edition it's joined by the
sportiest and most fuel-efficient
version of the compact classic to date
matas has also spotted the series
version of the beetle dune on the vw
stand
it has an extra 50 millimeters clearance
and an electronic differential lock that
gives it handling like its dune buggy
namesake
eye catching is the innovative ski rack
built into the rear spoiler
the mercedes benz stand also plays up
the luxury but without forgetting
practical concerns
montes reminds us that mercedes-benz
premiered the sedan version of its
c-class in geneva just a few months
previously and the station wagon version
the team model in bremen a couple of
weeks ago now here at leipzig the public
is getting its first glance of the
vehicle
with over 1500 liters of cargo space and
a wide range of engines it appeals to
business travelers and families alike
green is skoda's vision for the fair not
just because of its natural gas powered
gtech models but because of its vision c
designed to offer a preview of the czech
car maker's design vocabulary in years
to come
in technological terms the show cars
based on vw's modular architecture
germany head imelda
stresses that right now it's a prototype
but one that's already had a very clear
impact on the company's new models and
will definitely shape models to come
opal has had a long struggle with its
public image but that may well be over
its broad range of models and
alternative powertrains are aimed at
giving the make a new shine for all
classes of car buyers
opel sales and marketing director jurgen
keller says along with many innovations
and it's always important for opal to
have a german premiere in leipzig so the
atom rocks is making its debut at the
2014 ami he says that adam rocks caused
quite a stir last year as a prototype so
opal decided they'd go ahead and put it
out on the market
two hundred eighty thousand visitors
came to see the automotive industry's
latest creations at the last ami two
years ago with slightly more expected
this time around as the car makers see
it the more the merrier
contestant is taking porsche's new
panamera s e hybrid for a spin the first
thing she notices is how quiet it slips
along that's because of its electric
motor now she wants to see what
porsche's hybrid can do
porsche had already put out a hybrid
version of its panamera in 2010 but the
technology for the second generation is
a great leap forward
the panamera s e hybrids electric motor
is twice as powerful and its lithium-ion
batteries have five times the capacity
now that can be charged direct from a
regular outlet in hybrid mode the se
hybrid puts out 306 kilowatts of power
under the hood is a three liter v6
gasoline powered engine the electric
motor sits on the rear drive unit
between the engine and the transmission
the trunk offers plenty of room for the
recharging cable put the battery unit
right under the trunk floor
it can be charged in two and a half
hours from an industrial power socket
and in around four hours from a
household outlet
turned the key she could hardly even
tell if the engine was actually running
or not but a green day glow needle told
her the car was ready in other words the
car was on and ready to go
here are the specs at a glance the
plug-in hybrid leaps from zero to 100
kilometers per hour in 5.5 seconds
putting it on par with the power of a
classic v8 engine porsche rates the fuel
consumption of 3.1 liters of premium per
100 kilometers with co2 emissions of 71
grams per
anus kilometer that the car has three
driving modes an e-mode you're driving
on electric power the car is running on
the batteries only
turn the e-mode off and you're driving
in hybrid mode which means the gasoline
engine pitches in
this mode goes easy on the batteries
whose power is safe for city driving
if she wants to recharge the batteries a
little she selects the e-charge mode so
the car drives on gasoline power and the
batteries are recharged by regenerative
braking
for city driving in the purely electric
mode the panamera s e hybrid can range
from 18 to 36 kilometers
enos points out that the electric motor
makes a lot of sense in town because
it's free of emissions but you have to
be very careful since the car doesn't
make any noise meaning that you have to
pay especially close attention to
pedestrians and bike riders when
approaching them from behind often they
can't hear the car coming
inside the se hybrid featured the
exacted porsche luxury with lots of room
for the driver and passengers
and working the hybrid systems using the
switches on the center console is
child's play
enos finds the car's technology simply
fascinating that is the interaction of
gasoline and electric engines in hybrid
mode and how they mutually support one
another
at the same time she likes having
control over the system she can be
driving on the gasoline engine and
simply switch over to the electric motor
without ever noticing the difference
except that the tachometer drops to zero
to sum up
says this is a truly extraordinary
portion some drivers might miss the
familiar porsche sound like she did at
first but then you realize what kind of
technology you're dealing with and how
it's working behind the scenes almost
unnoticeably when you consider how much
has changed from one generation to the
next you get a sense of how much
potential remains for future progress
starting at nearly 111 000 euros in
germany the panamera and its green
technology certainly don't come cheap
but what porsche does the porsche is
simply an expensive car
each year the alps around kids brew host
a very special event and these are the
star attractions more than 200 classic
antique cars for three days they
transformed the austrian landscape into
an open-air automotive museum
it's a car lover's dream
she says she's been looking forward to
the event all year it's great fun and
even better when they finally get
underway now she just has to hope that
her car is up to the challenge in the
past some haven't managed it but this
one will she thinks because it's
kittspur the rally draws many
celebrities well-known actors and
athletes
is one of them nice people she says
great cars and it's a fantastic event
it's fun seeing all the roadsters and
vintage cars and the whole setup is a
gas too
the rally doesn't require speed it's
about skill and timing and the road book
is something special too it's a real
challenge even for extreme athletes like
felix baumgartner
bomb gartner tells us how it works
there's a time card and a stop watch you
have an unfamiliar car to contend with
this is a 1970 volkswagen beetle with
135 horsepower it's a rally beetle as
you can see from the interior and seats
it's a fun car to drive then there's the
road book the stopwatch the trip master
for a first timer it's a real challenge
he's got ambitions this time around so
he's got the owner to explain the car to
him
from
this year race car driver hans joachim
stuke has asked his son johannes to go
behind the wheel of his gold gti
super thank you
to get ready for the starting gun
celebrity chef johann laffer gives his
vw bus some pampering
a top up with some old pressed olive oil
nothing but the best will do
his baby is a type 2 volkswagen bus a
true original from 1967.
this one is off-white and sports 44
horsepower
a great car to coast along the alpine
roadways
in historic rotten bag there's a test
section straight through town but
there's an unexpected development
laffer needs some help but it's not a
technical breakdown he just simply ran
out of gas
he takes it with good humor driving with
no gas would be an amazing trick but it
never works
it's time to take on the alpine passes
for the vintage cars there's a real
challenge ahead the gross glockner high
alpine road
14 hairpin turns up to elevation 2 400
meters
some of these beauties are 70 years old
so the incline really puts them through
their paces and what do the drivers get
out of it he says it's all about the
pleasure of driving
he agrees the weather could be better
but he'll manage
this driver says it's about the cars an
antique car will outlast them all it'll
even be around for the next generation
if anything goes wrong with the car you
can always fix it back up again
this incline takes the engines to their
limits on the way back down it's the old
drum brakes that need to show what
they're made of and then there's the
time cards to contend with
at most antique car rallies it's not
about speed you have to do each leg in a
specified time and there's penalties for
being too late or too early
the gross glockner is supposed to take
23 minutes and 9 seconds
despite the almost wintry conditions
many of the drivers still took their
tops down
finally the cars crossed the finish line
in kittspur with thousands of fans here
to greet them
open top race cars elegant coupes
roadsters sedans it's all here
then there's the beautiful landscape and
the charming alpine town
what more could anyone ask for
this man agrees true antique car buffs
want to show off their cars they don't
want them to just sit in a garage
somewhere so a rally like this where
everyone's thrilled to see the cars and
enjoy them is a fantastic experience
you